in setting up this interviews or and I
think you said you're very used to
shooting guerrilla-style we're trying to
determine a place to shoot so for
someone who's so accustomed to doing
this and especially in LA because it's
that's a very very hard thing to do here
in LA I think people in other parts of
the world and country don't realize you
just can't walk into a park and start
shooting most places remember what are
the tips that you can advise other
people on uh in terms of how to do it
how to not get chased by security the
noise it's an incredibly noisy town yeah
oh yeah that did the noise that sets
that's something to take it think about
I was surprised films called the
questions I've got because we're
screening for homes come students and
advanced some questions and and I'm
trying to exactly those questions I was
a student now if I go back and ask
whoever made the film questions that
exactly very very very practical so like
how long or how would you shoot a
twilight scene to dialogue on the busy
street between two people and it's about
four minutes long you know and then you
say with four days you know two
different locations no permits and it's
the only waited and then how do you wire
that then how do you get the sound you
know so like exactly the dozer that
doesn't do those are the good questions
of nuts and bolts but as far as Alec I
mean we shot a lot of this without
permits you know and people see it in
eyes to Derek no [ __ ] way oh yeah you
know it just you kind of take a shot and
you know a few times we did encounter
cops it happens to they were kind enough
to you know not ram us too hard but you
know when a few times you work on you
know hastily even style but I think if
you can work all that in in a schedule
and you can say okay so you're sharing
this but if we do get shot down we're
picking up this the hair on this if you
kind of do approach it as a possibility
I think
there's enough holes I mean we shot San
Francisco and night pulling the car with
three girls partying with open bottles
and the cop car just like Drew around us
and wives chasing somebody else yeah San
Francisco and that was kind of cool cuz
we all kind of lost it there but in LA
yeah we shut down Sunset Boulevard you
know we put a camera on the car straight
shot to freeway tried on bars in the
frio and stuff so it's um we shot in the
cable car that was that was dead that
was exactly what I'm saying it was like
okay we got on the cable car you turn on
the camera will probably gonna have ten
seconds before they tell us to leave and
it's exactly what happened it was like a
playbook yeah I was tired of filming
told us to leave they stopped the camera
and we left but we did get exactly
enough of the footage that I knew we
could incorporate into montage and it's
in them it's in the trailer would you go
would you Scout the locations beforehand
or some of this just like on a whim most
the locations we scouted as far as LA
and we knew you know the festival
location I that was my first job in the
US I worked security at that high sierra
music festival like 20,000 people in the
campaign it's really cool it's just it's
mind-blowing and we knew that but I no
idea what are we gonna pick up on that
San Francisco shooting day you know it
just kind of went with the flow and
another thing is also a smaller crew I
think people are so forgiving if it's
you know three people and then actor
with a camera you can swing so much by
then if you have to drag trucks and
lighting and try to set up set you know
so that also i think plays up a plays a
big part it's how big the crew is I
think I've burness was kind of
a strong point I can be at a restaurant
with a cannon and you know can be
filming the dialogue and people not even
know where you're filming you know and I
just need to figure out the sound play
how do you handle innocent why standards
that just excuse me innocent just
bystanders who want to just look and
they they're just curious but they're
sort of in the way how do you yeah did
we you know I think rated yes yeah it's
called me happen you having a few times
that phone or like okay this is you are
part of this now but you know they
didn't mess up so many shots and it kind
of comes with it so as long as you try
to pray them I'm like advices I'm
horrible at it but if you can prepare
yourself for a list of things that could
happen and then try to extend it and
extend it and extend it that that's a
good way to approach it because all
these different things I mean honestly
putting a list might premiere by be
assassinated that day you know couldn't
it happen right you know i mean it's
it's it's and then cops stop and take
your camera because you know the
country's going crazy so I plan on the
crazy and then if it doesn't happen you
had a great day that's that's that's how
I approach it from now on so plan for
utter chaos and work backwards oh yeah
definitely plan on the couch def ok
there from then on the chaos
you